en la mano cuentas de aquí somos mujeres
perfecto
cuál es la parte que más odias de tu
cuerpo
cuál es ese detallito tuyo que te hace
sentir incómoda
insegura que no le quieres mostrar a
nadie
cuál es esa parte de tu cuerpo que si
pudieras cambiarla con el chasquido de
los dedos no lo pensaría dos veces
es más que una
tal vez son dos tal vez son cuatro tal
vez son diez aves son todas las que se
nos ocurran porque somos mujeres y todas
tenemos al menos una cosa que nos hace
sentir incómodas
pero realmente nos incomodaba a nosotras
o incomoda a alguien más
realmente crecimos odiando no
cuando fue sino hasta que alguien más
nosotros
que empezamos a creer que había algo mal
con nosotras mismas
no te pongas esa blusa porque te ves
gorda
no te pongas esos tacones porque eres
demasiado alta y ves intimidar a todos
no te peines de esa manera porque tu
frente se ve enorme no te pongas esos
colores esa marca no te vistas de esa
manera porque eres morena
tienes que depilarte aunque tú solo
tenía 13 años
casi como poesía
se dulce pero en palabras
se tierra pero no flexible
a más pero con recato
escucha pero no siempre creas
se digna pero no orgullosa
sé mujer pero en la muñeca
por qué
porque permitimos que se nos diga qué es
lo que podemos o qué es lo que no
podemos hacer porque permitimos que se
nos diga cómo debe ser una mujer que
vale la pena porque no podemos amar sin
medida porque no podemos reír a
carcajadas porque no podemos ser tiernas
porque no podemos ser dulces
porque nuestro valor se mira a través de
las decisiones que tomamos
siempre que estemos pensando
queremos ser mejor que las demás mujeres
siempre se nos ha enseñado que estamos
en medio de una competencia eterna
siempre se os ha enseñado a ser más
bonita más feliz más exitosa que la
mujer que tienes al lado
se os ha enseñado que como mujeres no
vamos a obtener nada fácil
y que aún cuando te esfuerces muchísimo
para obtener tus objetivos
si lo logras seguramente hiciste apto
para estar en dónde estás
se nos ha enseñado que la única manera
de estar conformes con nuestro cuerpo es
encontrar más efectos a la otra y que si
tú realmente te sientes bien contigo
misma seguramente está siendo presumida
y debes estar mintiendo
cuando vamos creciendo todos los
factores en nuestra vida apuntan a que
seamos infelices
a punto en el que estemos en medio de
una competencia eterna no solamente con
las demás en una competencia eterna
contigo misma
a que no te sienta satisfecha aunque
siempre estés buscando la felicidad en
factores muy alejados de tu realidad
cuando vamos creciendo se nos enseña
estar inconformes
a que nunca vas a ser perfecta
a que siempre tienes que cambiar tienes
que superar a las demás tienes que
superarte aquí
cuando entendamos esto
nos daremos cuenta de por qué nuestro
cuerpo
es nuestro primer campo de batalla
de tus manos
de verdad hazlo de tus manos
de tus piernas
de la manera en la que está sentada
de la ropa que te pusiste hoy
siente la textura de tu piel
siente la forma de tu cabello
date cuenta que eso que tú eres
es lo que te hace ser
date cuenta que ese cúmulo de carne y
hueso es lo único que te va a acompañar
para toda la vida
es lo único que te va a ayudar a
soportar todo todo por lo que tenga este
atravesar
todos tus miedos sus errores sus
fracasos sus decepciones
pero también todas tus alegrías todos
tus amores todos tus éxitos todos tus
logros todos los momentos de felicidad
cuando entendamos esto nos daremos
cuenta de por qué el amor propio y el
autocuidado es la única manera que
tenemos de decirnos a nosotras mismas
gracias
yo creo firmemente que el feminismo es
es accionar político y no me refiero a
esa política de colores y de partidos no
me refiero a esa política de campañas de
sexenio esa política de promesas a esa
política que vemos con un mundo muy
alejado de nosotras porque ser un mundo
tradicionalmente dominado por hombres
un mundo donde tradicionalmente no se
nos da cabida a las mujeres donde no se
nos escucha donde no se nos ve como
menos
me refiero a la política en el sentido
más simple de la palabra me refiero a la
política como nuestra existencia misma
como todas las decisiones que tomamos
como nuestro día a día
en un contexto
la infelicidad es la regla
en un ambiente donde todo apunta que
estemos infelices
todas las decisiones que tomamos por
estar bien por estar felices por sanar
por querernos a nosotras mismas y por
ser amor
somos un acto de rebeldía
cuando nos demos cuenta de que nosotros
podemos decidir por nosotras de que
podemos hacer lo que queramos
entonces empezaremos a cambiar la
relación que tenemos con todos los demás
no tendremos que limitarnos a lo que nos
están diciendo no tenemos que ajustarnos
de ser mujeres que valgan la pena
siempre nos dicen brillar
pero no brilla es demasiado porque si
brillas demasiado entonces incómodas
porque nos quieren pequeñas porque
calladita te ves más bonita pero eso no
es cierto
ponte de pie a la persona que tienes al
lado
de europa
ponte de pie y ve a la persona que
tienes al lado
de brad vela no nada más la mire vela
besos humanos
de su cabello de qué tan alta es el
color de sus ojos
bueno tal cual lo hiciste contigo misma
reconoce la y al hacerlo reconocido a ti
misma
y si te atreves abraza la
date cuenta de que así es como comienza
la sonoridad
pues no sepa su nombre lo sepas edad de
dónde viene o cuáles son sus problemas y
tal vez sí que tampoco está el papel
está un nombre de dónde vienes con esta
edad y cuáles son tus problemas pero aún
así están dispuestas a estar ahí la una
para la otra están dispuestos a abrazar
se están dispuestas a hacer un apoyo
porque así desde el anonimato es como se
construye la la sororidad es cómo se
construyen estas comunidades de apoyo
mutuo de saber que si vas a caer alguien
más de estar ahí para levantarte y que
si tú acá es la compañera que tienes al
lado te va a levantar
los cuerpos que sanan
son cuerpos que se emancipan en este
momento no nada más estas abrazando la
ella nos estamos abrazando entre todas y
sobre todo te estás abrazando a ti
relaciones más sanas relaciones de
felicidad y relaciones de amor
comienzan contigo
y comienzan cuando tu sanas y comienzan
cuando tu te vuelves amor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]